では よろしくお願いします
今日はダンマパダの七十八番目 Na
bhaje pāpake mitte na bhaje purisādhame
bhajeta mitte kalyāne bhajeta purisuttame
という偈になります これはおそらくパンディタは
という新しい章に入りますけど
この 一応賢者 智慧のある人というタイトルでいくつかの偈をまとめてあるところで
意味よりは言葉 似ている言葉で見て集めているところです Na
bhaje pāpake mitteっていうのは
このpāpakeっていうのは悪
悪人ということで mitte
っていうのは友人のことでね
だから悪友ですね 悪い友達とNa bhaje関わるなよと
付き合ってはいけません Na
bhaje purisādhame adhamaっていうのはものすごく卑しいという立場がないということ
まあこれも道徳的なことで
まあすごい性格悪い 卑しい人っていうのは社会的に測るものじゃないんです
道徳的にものすごく悪いことをする
罪を犯す そういう性格的に悪い人
卑しい人というんですね
そういう人々とはNa bhaje
付き合わない方がいいと
それでやってはいけないことを二行で言って
次はやるべきことを言うんですね bhajeta
mitte kalyāne kalyāne
っていうのは良い 善というね
善友と付き合いなさいと bhajeta
purisuttame purisa
っていうのは人間のこと uttama
っていうのは尊いということで
尊い人間と と付き合いなさいと
まあそういうことで そんなに珍しい意味でもない
読んだだけでも分かりますね
何をおっしゃっているのかということはね
一般的にも世の中で悪い人と付き合うなよということはね
一応お母さんも言ってくれるんだからね
最初から まあそれは まあそれぞれ家族の育ち方がどうかは分かりませんだけど
まあまあ我々にとっては別に小さい時から最初から言われてきたものなんです
大体古い人間だったら
自分たちのお母様たちはね
やっぱり同じことを言ったと思いますよ
現代はどうか分かりませんだけどね
悪い人と付き合わないよとね
悪い友達と関わるなよと
悪い仲間と付き合ってはいけませんということなんですね
それはそんな珍しい話じゃないんです
それでなんでそこが悪いのかという問題なんですね
なんで悪い人と縁を切らなくちゃいけないのかと
なんででしょうかね それって常識的にはわかると思いますけど
はい 勇気を出して言う言える方々いれば
影響を受ける 影響悪い影響を受ける
他の提案がありますか？なんで別に悪い人であったって
もう付き合って何が悪いんですかね
日本には朱に交われば赤くなるという諺があって
悪い人と付き合えば悪くなる
良い人と付き合えば良くなりますよ
だからですかね  そうだと思います
一緒に悪いことをしてしまう可能性がある
単純にトラブルに巻き込まれて苦労させられるから
はい まあ別に誰もこの言葉さえ自分四字熟語を思い出したりして生活を直そうとは思わないんです
まあだからまあ単純な答え
こちらが言った答えなんですね
影響を受けるんだからなんです
だから付き合うなよと
人と付き合うっていうことは
やっぱり互いに影響を受けることなんですよ
影響を受けることがなければ
そちらで付き合いということも成り立ってないんです
だから誰かと付き合っているという
付き合うというかね 一応関わりを持って生きるというね
友達として仲良くしているということは
当然お互いに影響を受け合っているということになります
そこはすごいしっかりと覚えておかなくちゃいけないんです
人との付き合いってどういうことかというと
これ体で付き合いじゃないでしょうに
体はそれぞれ別々なものだからね
一緒にご飯を食べたっても
それぞれ別々に食べてるんだからね
そういう物理的な関わりはないんです
あるのは心の関わりなんです
だからそれぞれ自分で行って弁当を買ってきても
二人で一緒に食べる場合は
もう自分が買ってきた弁当は自分が食べていて
相手が買ってきた弁当を相手が食べてるだけの話なんです
そちらで物質的な交換はないんです
それでも一緒に座ってご飯を食べる場合
やっぱり心の関わりが起きているんです
だから我々しっかり覚えておかなくちゃいけないポイントは
この生命との付き合いということは
確実にこの心の繋がりなんです
心っていうのは影響を与えたり受けたりするものなんです
ですから 日本語で言う何でしたっけ
あれは  朱に交われば うん
それはあまり正しい言葉じゃないんです
そこで考えるのは必ず自分が影響を受けるだけの話で
一方的に 一方的じゃないんですよ
どんなグループにいたら一人ぐらい別な人が悪い
例えば悪い人が来たりすると
そのグループが壊れてしまうでしょうね
そのグループに影響を受けるかどうかね
例えば あるグループに一人が入る
入ったところで その入った人はそのグループの同じ影響を受けて同じようになってしまう可能性もあるし
あるグループに誰かが入ったところで
グループの中ものすごくバラバラになっちゃって
その人の影響を受けることもありますよ
だからその両方気をつけて言葉作らない
作らないと 悪い仲間であっても
例えば悪いことをする仲間がいる
それでもあなたも入ってくれませんかと誰か頼んで入れてもらったところで
その人の影響で悪いことを全部なくなってしまったということもあり得るんです
逆もあります 良いことをする仲間の中に私も入れてくれという人が入ってきたところで
あの良いことしていた仲間がそれから悪いことをすることになったということもあります
だから影響を受け合うことだから
強い人の影響は弱い人は受けるということはやっぱり一般的な法則なんです
だから断言的にね まあどこかに悪いところに行っただけで
もう自分が必ず影響を受けて
向こうと同じ かかることになるということはないんです
そういうことを学んでおいた方が問題はしっかりすると思います
それで一緒に交わればかかるっていうことはどんな時ですかね
まあ正しいなのは 交わった人はもうすごい気が弱い場合ですよ
心が強い場合はそうなりませんね
それが一つの法則 方程式で
法則で覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですね
影響は互いに受けます
どうせ気が弱い人が丸ごと受けることになるんです
次のポイントは どうしても誰かの仲間に入りたいと
人と付き合いたいと 友達を作りたいと思っている人の場合なんですね
なんで人と作り 付き合いたい
交わりたいと思うのかというと
やっぱりその人は心が弱いということなんです
自分で友達を作りたい
作りたいと 付き合う人々を作りたいと思っている場合は
当然自分の心が弱いということになります
だからその人がやっぱり危ないんです
だから その人にとってはもう寂しくて
もう誰でもいい状況 誰でもいいんだから友達が欲しいってことでしょ
だからとても危険なんです
だから友達を欲しくて探し求めている人々はとても危険で
誰でもいいんだからということになってしまっちゃって
たまたま誰かと話し合うことできちゃったりすると
向こうはすごくしがみついて
もうなかなか離してあげないということになっちゃうんですね
それどうなるのかというと
その相手の影響は受けてしまうことになります
[背景の雑音]で 心が強い人っていうのは別にまあ誰か誰かと付き合いたい
付き合いたいとはね 思って思わないんですね
そこで心が強いっていうことはどういうことかというと
悪人の場合は まあ俗世間では悪人ってすごいすごい強いと勘違いするんですけど
本当はすごく弱いんです
大胆な悪行為をする人々は心が強いわけじゃないんです
すごく弱いんです だから悪人はいつでもグループを組んでるんです
それはすごい一致団結している
なかなか壊れないグループなんです
マフィアとかね ヤクザとかね
すごいしっかりしたグループありますよ
だから決まり守るはもうなかなか出て
もう一旦入ったらね 絶対そこは離れませんしね
それでなんでやと言ったら親分はすごいやと言って
それは違いますよ 一番気が弱いの
その親分なんです この悪いことをするテロリストのグループとかね
一番腰抜けがこのリーダーなんです
出てこないんです 前に
自分がもう徹底的に隠れる
だからこの 例を出したって意味がないんですからね
皆様 世間のことには興味はないしね
まあだから言っても それってどういうことかとね
私もあまりデータを覚えるつもりがないんだからね
中途半端でしか言えないんです
いろんな国々でそういうね
あのテロリストグループとかね
そういういろんな違法
違法というかね そういう暴力を振るったり
反社会的な運動をやったりする人々っていうのは
いろんなネパールに自分の国でもいるし
このアルカイダという組織もあるし
結構ありますね なんか無い国が無いぐらいですよ
もうロシアにもいるし
アメリカには当然いるし
この間ネパールでしたっけ？どこでしたっけ？そのいろいろ何とかというね
何運動でしたっけ  マオイストですか
マオイスト そのリーダーが出て外へ出てきたんですよ
もうそこ じゃあ政府みんなで話し合って仲良くやります
外へ出るためには あらゆる条件つけてつけてつけてつけてつけて
じゃあ出て出ていこうではないか
そういうふうじゃないんです
こうしなきゃ出ていききません
こうしなきゃ出ていけませんとかね
とにかく自分の命だけ完全に守ってあげるぞということになったところで
もう出てきて 社会に出て
もう一応政治活動に参加するぞと
で またちょっと都合が悪くなったでしょうね
また隠れることに決まったんです
また隠れて また人殺し始まるんです
だから この悪巧みやってる人々を一番もう腰抜けで気が弱いんです
自分の頃でも 20年もこの人殺しやってるテロリストグループがいて
とにかくもう一つ悪い手段以外何も使わないんですね
使って人殺したりして
それである時期で まあヨーロッパやらね
キリスト教のグループやら
いろいろ政府に悪口言って言って言って言って
もうそんなに良い人なのに
何であんたかと話し合わないか
あれやこうやとかね それで一回なんかアメリカのニュース番組か BBC か何かとかね
出してやるぞと このテロリストのリーダーをと
それで誰にも行けないんですけど
そちらにはその入ってる方にも一応入ることは向こうは許したんですね
許して まあ国際的にこの人をもう聖人化しようかなというね
BBC やら CNN やらそのからくりで
しかし ある記事 それもまあアメリカの記事なんですけど
ニュースか何かだと思いますけど
で やっとこの人にはね
世間の舞台に出る場が出ましたけど
結局は喋りしゃべることさえもできないんです
腰抜けで 人殺しなら何でも命令する
そこでまあどうせ何でしたっけ？ジャーナリストたちだからね
まあいくらなんでも国際ジャーナリストたちでしょうし
BBC やら CNN とこ行っちゃうと
もうかなりの大物たちでしょ
だからビシビシ質問する
質問するたびに もう彼にいろいろアドバイスする
イギリス人何人かいるんですね
もうそいつらの方を見て
もうどういう質問ですか
どんな意味で聞いたりして
向こう周りの人々を答えるんだそうです
何も喋らなかったと そんなにも自分で世間に向けて訴えたいことあれば言えばいいでしょうに
だからアルカイダのあの人
何でしたっけ？ビンラディンにしても
どこかで隠れてテープ一つ吹き込んでアルジャジーラに送るだけでしょう
それも本人は送らないんです
誰かわからない 誰かが郵送するだけで
俺は子供に頼んだって
お前これは郵送しなさいと
それでアルジャジーラが調べたら
もうどこから郵送されたと見ても
そこら辺誰か あんた何でどこへか
あるおじいさんがこれくれたんだから郵送したんだ
そこで終わっちゃうんですね
そこまで隠れるんです
そこで本当にビンラディンのテープか
あるいは誰かのごまかしかとかね
もう日本にしたってもね
もうなんて言いますかね
真似ですかってね もう真似する芸人っていうのはもう腐るほどいるでしょうね
だから誰かのね 声の真似かどうかわからない
それでまたいろんな研究所で音声分析して
もういえ これは本物だとかなんとか言わなくちゃいけない
そこまで隠れるんですね
なのに世間の愚かさっていうのは
この悪人にすごく力があると思っているんです
一番腰抜けっていうのは悪をやってる人々なんです
だからこそ その組織っていうのはものすごく強いんです
なかなか壊れにくいんです
だって一人一人が腰抜けだから
一緒にいた方がいいんです
このミツバチとかね このコロニー生活している動物
虫たちいるんですね 1
匹別にとってしまって持っていっちゃうと死にます
もう何もできない ただミツバチでもね
いっぱい花のみつを集めてものすごい仕事をしているでしょうね
それでみんなそれなりに寿命ある間は元気で生活していますけど
ではミツバチ一匹持ってきてら餌も食べられないんです
何もできない だから持ってきて
ちゃんとした花のあるところに買ってあげたっても死ぬだけ
こんなたくさん花あるのに水ぐらい取って飲めと
飲まないんです そこでミツバチやらシロアリやらね
アリやらね そういうコロニー生活している虫たちの中で
みんなこの女王のために必死で頑張っているでしょう
卵を産むのはね 女王だから
そうなってくるとそちらが強いでしょうと
全く反対なんですよ 自分では何もできないんです
だからあのミツバチの女王であろうとシロアリの女王でも取ってしまえば死ぬんです
そちらも 餌さえも食べられなくなるんです
食べさせているんだからね
だから この 一致団結するっていうことは弱いっていうことなんです
本当は それで日本に誰かの大名の話あるでしょ
山谷の話を持ってきてね
これはあの なんか兄弟喧嘩している場合はね
毛利  毛利さんの話ですね
あれは 日本でもあるし
インドでもそういう物語があるんですよ
で ジャータカ物語も何かあるような気がしますけど
はっきり覚えてないんですけど
インド文化の物語の中でもありまして
この王子たちに教育させる場合はね
みんな森に行って もう枝を持ってきてということで
枝と言ったっても薪ですね
で 持ってきてみんなでじゃあ折ってみなさいと言っちゃうと
みんな薪を何のことなくパチッと折ったりするんですね
ああ そうか すぐ折れるか
では束にしてくださいと
じゃあ折ってみなさいと言ったら折れないんです
だからあんた方はね お互い喧嘩するんじゃないよと
敵にやられますよと 一緒にいれば敵に敵の攻撃を受けませんと
いうことを このみんなで一つにまとめて団結するということは力になりますね
ということは 一人一人がすごく弱いということになるんです
[no sound]そういうわけではっきりした組織がある場合は
それは当然悪人の組織なんですよ
悪人の組織はそう簡単には潰れません
昨日か一昨日のニュースかわかりませんだけど
いろいろ名前変えて形を変えて
この麻原のグループがね
いろいろ活動しているんだと
しかし みんな未だに真剣
真面目に麻原という死刑囚を信仰しているんだから
名前変えても変えても
警察はそれからもずっと監視するんだと
だから信者さんの数はなかなか減らないという
で しっかりと活動している
そんなにも何でお互い何かすごい教えでもあるかというと何もないでしょう
だからこの悪人のグループっていうのは
そうなかなか潰しにくいんです
理由は一人一人がものすごい弱いっていうこと
だから誰かにもう徹底的に依存していないと生活できないんです
そこは世の中にある普通なシステムで覚えておいた方がいいんです
いつでも嘘ばっかし考えて嘘ばっかり事実だと思っているんだから
私が言っているのは本当に事実なんです
本当のことなんです いくら嫌がったとしても
私は知ったことじゃないんです
だから 一般的には まあ集に入っちゃうと
そこ同じことになってしまうということは
一般的にはあり得ることなんです
世の中を見てみると 何かの集にグループに流行しているのは
その人腰抜けだからでしょ
初めから だから当然かくなるっていうこと
結果にはなります で 法則はまた別ですけどね
法則はやっぱり強い人の影響は弱い人を受けるということは心の法則なんです
で 一番腰抜けの気が弱い人が何か仲間作って
仲間には出ていかないことにして
そこでもう人グループ作ってもそこは強いでしょう
それも人だからね すると番目
番目 番目 番目 入る入るたびにあのグループに一緒になっちゃって
どんどん力強くなるんです
それでこう壊しにくい組織が成り立っちゃうんです
それが番目の世の中の事実というふうに理解した方がいいんです
はっきり何が言いたいかというと
必ずしも人に友達がいなければいけないという決まりはないんです
必ずしも友達がいなくてはいけませんという決まりもないんです
では 一人でしっかりと生活できるのかと
人間にはね 人間はもう友達もいらんという人間もいますけど
それを見ると大変なことで
あまりにわがままで 社会のこと
環境のことを無視していい加減に生活したいんですね
だから友達も親も誰もいりませんと言ったりするんです
それはだから当然暗くなっちゃうんですよ
その場合は 人との付き合いはしませんだからね
当然暗くなって 社会から何の影響も応援もないんだから潰れてしまいます
だからどうしましょうかと
しかし 必ずしも人には友達いなくちゃいけないってそんな法則成り立ちません
それで一人が じゃあ私は一人で生活してみるぞと言ってて
あまりにも自我が強すぎちゃって
間もないうちに潰れてしまいます
何もできなくなっちゃって
心が強いのは良いことをする人々なんですね
心清らかな人 悪いことをしない人ね
善行為をする人 初めからしっかりしているんです
だから悪いことをしない人だから
どうせ自我があるわけでもないんです
その人々は一人でいたっても潰すことはできないんです
周りには潰す必要もないんです
わがままあるわけでもないし
自我が張ってるわけじゃないし
何かあったら相手を助けてくれないわけでもないし
だから潰す必要は出てこないんです
一人でいても だから心が強いっていうのは決まって善行為をする心良い心を持ってる人に限るんです
悪いことっていうのは
その時点でもう気が弱い
悪いことをした時点でも
悪い思考を持った時点でもう気が弱いんです
それで仲間が必要になっちゃうんです
そこまで世間の話でね
はい そういう世間に対してお釈迦様が何を語るのかという
今まで説明したのは世間の状況
人間の状況 お釈迦様が何を語るのかというと
やっぱり良い人間になりなさいということなんですね
だから結局心が強くなるはずなんですね
それで最終的にはお釈迦様は独立を語っているんです
完全たる善人になった人は完全に独立しているんだと
孤独を楽しむんだと 孤独じゃなくて孤独を楽しむんだ
そこはすごい自慢げに謳っているんです
[紙をめくる音]スッタニパータではね
あの腕は二つ だいたい僕は腕は使いますからね
首はよりも腕に 首 何て言いますか
ここら辺に何かこちらのもの
上につけるものもありまして
下につけるものもあって
それに二つつけておくと五月蠅いんだと
歩くたびに手を動かすたびにこれ音を立てますからね
だから二つ付き合うっていうことはかなり煩わしいんだよと
だから一人で生活するんだよと
ということで それはもう一般の人にできることじゃないんです
できるというか 理解もできないんです
だからあの経典は日本ですごく人気あるんです
あの犀の角の如くという経典はね
人気あるだけじゃなくて
馬鹿者たちは実行までしようとするんです
もう勘違いもいいところです
実行するところが理解できるのかと聞きたいんですけど
言ってることは それはもう完全たる聖者の完全たるというか
善を完了した一切の依存を断ち切った人の話であって
普通の人間には何の関係もないんです
あれは日本訳もできないんです
辞書の意味を入れ替えただけで
それでは意味は通じてないんです
ものすごい原文では 四行読めば
もうこれで今日一週間十分だよというくらいすごい意味があるんです
四行読んだらもう十分やと
頭にはもう消化できないんだと
まあ残念なことに それはパーリ語から離れると
そこはもう意味が全部落ちるんですからね
だから結局はお釈迦様はそれを語ってますよ
この人に誰かに依存するっていうことは
腰が弱いということに決まってるんだから
だからそこはもう次元が違う
もう聖者の世界で 聖者でない人にはいくら考えたって
もうこれはもう思考の範囲を超えている世界のことです
まあそういうわけで 仏教は今みんな一致団結して繁栄しなさいという話はあまり成り立たないんです
みんなで団結してチェカラセを行って繁栄するということは
みんなずっと弱いまんまで
互いに依存して生きるということになっちゃうんです
だから仏道というのは依存を断つこと
実行してみるんです だからそこはできるところから始めて
ゆっくりゆっくり依存する数をどんどんどんどん減らして減らして減らして減らしていくんです
出家というシステムができたのも
いきなり出家ということがなったわけで
ものすごい大量の依存をいきなり捨てるんです
本物の出家はね 形ではなくて
出家しても関係 あれもこれもそのままもう引き続けている人いますけどね
それは仏教では悪坊主やというんですからね
生臭坊主というのはそういう人々のことなんです
生臭そのままということでね
本当の出家っていうのは
この全部この縁をそこで切るんですよ
それは覚悟の上で かなり自分にとってはきついんだと
きついんだけど切るんだと
切ったところで自分の心がその分が強くなるんですね
それからどんどんどんどんもうまた切って切って切って切って切って切っていくんです
もうやがて切る縁もなくなってしまったところで
もう完全たる境地に達しているんです
そういう長い道順ですが
まあ例えばカーヤパリハリケーナ
チーワレーナ クッチパリハリケーナ
ピンダパーテーナ ジーワンカッペンティとかね
出家はどう生活するかというと
もう体に纏う纏っておいてぐらいの服はそこで終わりと
衣はね ちょっと身に纏う程度で
他全部カットする おしゃれ服やらもうもういっぱい保管してね
まあその週毎日交換して着るとかね
で 行事に合わせる 合わせるいろいろ服とかね
結婚式に葬式にあれやこれやとかね
パーティーにとかね そういうのは全て切って全て依存だからね
ただ体を隠せる量で これなら隠せる
それで着ると 食べ物の場合はあれやこれや
グルメとか美味しそうじゃなくて
まあ口に入る程度で結構やと他全部まあいわゆるお腹にちょっと入れられる程度で十分で
他全部切ってしまうというね
だからまあそういうふうにこの依存を切るというね
で 修行方法なんです だから依存にどっしりと入っている人にとっては
すごく嫌な世界で感じるんです
なんで依存解いてないのかと
嫌で感じたっても ちゃんと依存を切る方法で進んでいる人々の明るさと清さを見て
まだすっごく羨ましがるか
もうそれまた嫌がるんですね
何かケチをつけてやろうと思ったりするんです
だから昔もインドはお釈迦様の時代でもね
やっぱりなんでこの出家の人々は誰よりも明るくニコニコとするんでしょうかと
その連中には何もないでしょうと
ケチつけてみようとするんです
いるところも住むところもないわ
何もないんだと これで頭を剃っていることに「ケーチェ・ムンダカ
ケーチェ・サマナカ」というすっごい侮辱言葉パーリ語で記録していますからね
そういうふうに言われているんだよと
バンドゥパーダ・パッチャ
梵天 梵の神様の足の裏から生まれた連中じゃないかとか
いわゆる不可触民族扱いされているんです
ブッダの沙門たちを それで偉そうなことを言うだけで
そこでお釈迦様からクタクタやられますけどね
もうもうもうものすごいことをやられますけど
そういうお釈迦様 その人々の宗教組織システムまで崩す
壊れ壊してしまうんです
何のことなくニコニコと
ああそうですかと 中部経典であるね
一つの若者がね 十六歳ぐらいでね
バラモン人でね 天才なんですよ
十六 十八でね あの だいたい四十歳
四十五 五歳 五十歳になるまでずっと学ぶものあるんです
何もこいつはもうあまりにも天才だから全部終わってるんです
それで偉大なるバラモンたちがこれが宝物やと
この若者のことをものすごく大事にする
そんなこと昇格して この長老と同じ格
格に入れてあげたんです
目上の人を山をね 仕切たりある世界だからね
だからこの自分が同じ格で扱ったんだからといって
先生たちにいろいろもう失礼なことを
侮辱なことをしようと
それはしなかった すごく良い若者で
それでいくつかのそういう出来事をね
もういろんなところで記録してますからね
一つのケースだけじゃないんですけどね
まあこの人がこのカースト制度で
まあブッダと争論しようではないかと
自分たちも聖職者完全たる心清らかにするためには
バラモンカーストで生まれなくちゃあかんと
なぜならばバラモンというのは神様が口で作ったものやと
王家は腕で作ったんだと
他の民衆は太もものところで作ったんだと
不可触民族は足の裏から作りましたと
っていうカースト制度がありまして
神と一緒になれるのはバラモン人だけやと
何お釈迦様何言ってるんですか？と
バラモン人でもないでしょうということで
これおかしいと ありえないと
で それで先輩の先生たちとも話し合ってね
これで話し合いましょうと
あの人ともう自分の町に来たんだからと
で よし 君はもう天才だからね
あの人を潰すのは君しかいないんだよと
お釈迦様が年上でしょうしね
で来たんでね 来て話し口挟もうとすると
お釈迦様は黙っているよと
年上の人 喋る人 それは黙っているんだったんです
最初からもうこの人のプライドを傷つくんです
傷つくようにするんで
わざと それで問題に本人と喋ることになって
あんたの名前なんですかと
家の名前 それは自分の家系の名前言ったんですね
ただ 本人がこの伝説の謂れを持ってきて
ブッダが卑しいんで 自分たちが偉いというポイントを持ってきたいんです
持ってくる前に お釈迦様が君の家の名前は何ですか？と言ったら
家の名前って 君はその名前の謂れ知ってますか？と
同じ論理で伝説は大事に重んじると
言ったら まああんまり知らないみたいですね
それで じゃあ私知ってますから言いますよと言って
このその家柄の初めは説明して
昔このシャトゥル職である王家の人がいて
あれ奴隷の女の人と できちゃって妊娠させて子供が生まれたんだと
それで母親が奴隷だからね
もうどうしようもないんです
しかし 父親がもう大きな人だから
子供は捨てたくはないんです
だからといって一緒に育てることもちょっと問題がありまして
それでも子供を取って育てたんだと
しかし その子は自分にはもう立場がないんだから
であまり差別されるんだから出て行っちゃったんです
名前を その人 その人々の流れよと
あんたはと 言ったら これがもう伝説伝承で事実でどうすることもできなくなったんです
だから言ったら あんた偉そうに自分の家柄が偉いと何言ってるんです
元辿ってみたらそんなことやと
だからそんなことを問題に持ってくるなよということなんです
人間は道徳だよと いきなり本人が立場がなくなっちゃって
バラモン人だって我々なんてことをして
こいつは家柄が良くないんだと
もう降ろさなくちゃいけないんだと
みんなバラモンたちはさあさあ
一斉にもう批判を始めたみたいです
若者がすっごく真っ青になっちゃって
落ち込んじゃって もう言葉も出てこない状態になっちゃったんですね
だからその人にとっては
もう自分のプライドっていうのはひとかけらもなく潰されたと
もう人の前でバラモン人が偉いと
もう死ぬ間際 死ぬまで言えなくなっちゃったんだから
そこは一つ その偉いで
それでバラモンたちがまたこの若者を批判しようと批判するんだから
むちゃくちゃ だから何のことなく
その人々にあんた方何言ってるんでしょうかと
なんでこの若者を非難するんでしょうかと
言って またそちらに学習するんです
あんた方には何のこともないでしょうと
あんた方は なぜならば
この人の家柄の名前を取ったこの一番最初の人がすごい人でしたと
本当に仙人でしたと 本物の
瞑想してもうサマーディを得て
で 亡くなるところでみんなに見られるように幻想を作って梵天に行って生まれ変わったんだ
そういう人々の遺伝だよと
あんた方にそんなのあるのかという調子で黙っていろよと
だからどちらも潰しちゃった
潰すんですよ まあそれからまあ普通に話を言って
まあ問題に答えて まあ人間っていうのは価値っていうのはね
まあそういう道徳にあるっていうことね
これは家柄は関係ないんだと
もうただみんな人間であるという
仏教的な信条をずっと教えていくんです
そこまではかなり大変な厳しいことをしなくちゃいけなくなるんです
まあということで 仏教はね
まあ普通理解できることというか
難しいといえば難しいんですよ
難しいんだけど ちゃんとしっかりと学んでみれば
もうなるほどとわかるんです
インド社会でも もうとにかく何かに依存する
何かに依存するというね
最終的には宗教になってくると
神に依存するということを教えちゃうんですね
神に仏様に阿弥陀様に依存しちゃうとね
これまたずっと弱いままということになっちゃうんですね
だからそれは解脱の悟りの道ではないんです
だから社会でどんな感情があっても
これには 場合じゃないんです
やっぱり一応は全部捨てなさいというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
だから全部捨てなさいって
我々人間にとっては はいはい
捨てましたっていうことにはありえないんです
だから まあよく自己観察して
して して どんどんどんどんどんどんこのいろんな関係を切って
切って 切って切って関係切ったっていうことは
心が強くなったっていうことだからね
それ両方ないと ただ関係切っただけでも意味がないんです
子供は家出したんだからといって
それだけでは意味がないんです
家出したならば しっかり独立して自分の人生を築かなくちゃいけないんですよ
偉そうに家を出て 田舎から出てきたんですけど
ろくな人生やってない
東京に来て 意味がないんです
だから  これ普通社会で皆さんわかる例でしょうしね
もう偉そうにわーっと喧嘩して出ていきますけど
それはそれでいいんだけど
それだったら自分の世界築きなさいよと
また田舎へ戻るはめになったりとか
もう最悪ですよ だから田舎に戻って悪くはない
戻る場合はもうみんな圧倒される
あの子帰ってくるんだよと
という村 みんな大騒ぎするような存在でなければ意味がないんです
はい 次のポイント 人間ではなくて
どんな生命でもどういう生命としての生き方なんです
で 仏教で輪廻転生ということは言ってますけど
で それってあまり面白くないんですよ
輪廻転生っていうのは
信じもまだ生まれ変わりますから
全然面白い話じゃないんです
ただ事実だから言うんであって
本当はすごい暗い話なんです
なぜかというと この生命っていうのはこの一つ一つユニットでできていて
それで亡くなったらその終わりなんですね
それでまたまるっきり新しい人生がそこで命が現れるんですよ
そこをまた初めからやらなくちゃいけないんです
ということは 皆様 人間で生まれた時は何も知らない
ものすごい無知なる過去あったのに
初めからも全部学ばなくちゃいけないんです
それで一人前になって
大きくなって もういろんな偉そうなことをやったりして
またくたびれて死んじゃうでしょうね
それで続けてできない
また初めからスタートなんです
だから生命が一つのユニットで生きていて
それで死んじゃったら
また新しい別な生命で現れるんだから
それまた初めからからスタートしなくちゃいけない
これからスタートしていくと
また死んじゃいますでしょうに
またからなんです だから過去があったっても
私は過去世は何なのかとか知りたがる人々いるでしょうね
何の役にも立ちませんよ
それはみんな興味あると言っちゃうと
もうかなりインチキの詐欺の人々はもう過去世を語ってくれますよ
日本でもそういう宗教組織あります
人のあなたの過去はこうでした
ああでしたと言ってくれる
それはもう明確に嘘を言っていてね
本人納得することを言えばいいんだからね
知ったって意味がないんですね
初めからスタートしなくちゃいけないんです
人間死んじゃって犬で生まれたとしましょう
人間にいた時のことで何にも役に立たないんですよ
それからそれから犬として生きるために必要なものは
から学ばなくちゃいけないんです
犬がそれで年ぐらい年取って死んだところで
例えば蛇に生まれ変わったとしましょう
それで犬でいたの年は全部で何の役にも立たない
蛇の人生は違いますから
それからまたから蛇として生きることを学ばなくちゃいけないんです
そういうわけで 輪廻転生っていうのは事実だけであって
喜ぶものじゃないんです
ああ いいなと思うものじゃないんです
輪廻っていうのはもう本当は厭離するべき
嫌うべきものなんです
いい加減やめたいと思うべきものなんです
何の得もないんです では
良いことをする人は死んだら天国に生まれるんではない？生まれますよ
で 生まれたら最悪で またそこでゼロから神として生活することを学ばなくちゃいけないんだから
では 親戚に言ってあげようとかね
子供たちに 孫たちに 私
俺が神になったんだから
おじいさんがとかね 何もできんよ
そこまた生まれたばっかりだからね
新米だから そんな出しゃばったことはできん
これ勘違いでしょ 死んだおじいさんがもうずっと守ってるとかね
向こうももうもう九十歳で偉大なるおじい様がいてね
もう亡くなったっても
もう生まれたばっかしで何もできん
自分のおじい様は日本の歴史にも名前が残っているんだぞとかね
人間国宝で勲章もあっていて
おじい様だよとか それはそうかもしれませんだけど
死んじゃったらまたゼロからスタートなんです
で そこで何が私はポイントに持っていきたいというと
こういうことなんです
私たちはゼロからスタートだから
当然学ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
当然人から学ばなくちゃいけないんです
これは決して避けることはできないんです
だから この学ぶという単語
パーリ語ではスッカですからね
それをはっきり言えば躾という単語にした方がもっと正しいんですよ
算学とか仏教あるでしょ
戒定慧というね あれは躾でもいいんです
躾がないとうまくもうどうにもならん
そこで人間の面白いことは躾嫌なんですね
あれってどういうことですか？へりくつです
躾は嫌と思ったら もうその生命ユニットはもう終わり
もう続かないんです 親に口答えするは
先生に口答えするは もう会社に入ったら一緒に仕事する人に口答えするはとかね
もう成り立たないんです
[背景音楽]だからこの輪廻の話持ってきたのは
この躾というものは これまた運命みたいなもんでずっとついてくるんです
この嫌な躾は関連してついてくるんです
だから一番手っ取り早い簡単な方法というのは
躾は嫌がらないことなんです
そんなのは当たり前 当然なことであると思っちゃえば
もうすぐもう楽になるんです
それは当然のことだよ
だからいつでもまあ学んでもらおうと
そうなってくると緊張したり
あれこれ何もないんで
どんな環境に行っても
こちらで何が学ぶべきかということをさっさと学んでもらっちゃえば問題起きません
これ躾嫌だからね やっぱり年下の人から若者からもう恥ずかしいでしょうとかね
お前若いくせに何言うんですかと大人に向かってとか言ってる人々いるでしょうに
それさえも成り立たない
年は関係ないんです そのそのところに行ったら
もう誰から学ぶ羽目になるかわからないんです
だから躾嫌では嫌と思っちゃうと人生を生きていられないんですからね
躾は当然もうついてくるものなんです
これを捨てることはできない
躾の義務から解放することはあり得ないんです
輪廻転生する限りは 最後の最後までも学ぶものはあるんです
そのポイントですよ だから誰と付き合っているのかっていうことは大事なことなんです
それ仏教の世界になってくると
あなたは誰と付き合っているのかということで
あなたは全部決めますよと
だから激しく選別するんです
悪人と付き合わないことにして
善人と付き合うことにするんです
相手が悪人とわかったら
何の躊躇もなく縁を切らなくちゃいけないんです
それが強さなんです 間違って悪い仲間に入ったっても
すぐ縁を切るという これ悪い仲間やと
今日限り終わりやと なんと言われても
そこを切った方がいきなりすごい心強い人間になるんです
そういうことで この人が悪い仲間に入ってるんだっていうことで
あの人は終わりやと 死刑やということじゃないんです
その人が気づいた瞬間で縁切ったら
もう何倍もすごい強い人間になっているんです
悪人と仲良くして そこで縁を切ったりしたっても
その人は悪人の影響を受けてますからね
それからどうやって生活するかわからないんだから
それからやっぱり善人と付き合って学んでもらわないといけないんですね
私はヤクザを辞めたある若者
若いんですけどね まあ歳ぐらいかな
喋っている話を見ていた
聞いていたんですね まだまだ体形とかね
かなりヤクザっぽくでしたけど
でも他の人はすごい厳しく人に物事を言うんですね
もっと若い人々に厳しくね
そんなことやってはいかんとかね
堂々と 私はヤクザでしたからね
ああいうグループでこんなことやる
こういうことやる こういうことやるとかね
で 本人よく困っていたのは
この友達 前のまだまだ友達で知り合いだから
時々来ますよと これ困るんだと
その連中は悪い嫌なビデオを持ってきたりとかね
自分の家で見たがったりする
私はもう全部やめたんだから
そんなって言って 他の年下の人々に案内するんです
考えたら この人はね ヤクザのグループに入っていて
それは嫌やと思って出て行ったところで
普通の人間よりしっかりしている人のことまで心配する
年下の人々にもしっかり生きてなさいとアドバイスできる人間まで成長しているんです
だから この縁を切るということは
いかに人の信を強くしてくれるのかと
ということなんです ですから
世の中の教えの中でね
もうとにかく依存ばっかり教える教えってのは良くないんですよ
神を信じなさいとか 仏様を信じなさい
あれ信じなさい これ観音様を信じなさいとかね
もう何かに依存しなさいというね
そういう教えではないんです
だから この依存をカットするために
お釈迦様は友仁という言葉はあえて単語を使っているんです
友人と付き合いなさい
戦友と付き合いなさいよと
信じなさいはないんです
そこでお釈迦様とも付き合いなさいということになるんです
お釈迦様を徹底的にキリスト教の方々
神を信じるような感じで信じるではないんです
信じちゃうと ずっともう弱いままで終わってしまうんですね
付き合うんです だからお釈迦様が言うのは
戦友と付き合いなさい
戦友と付き合うと一切の苦しみがなくなりますよと言って
あんた方知ってますかね？この世の中で一番トップクラスの最高たる戦友は誰ですかと
それは私だよと ブッダのことということを
お釈迦様自分が戦友であると宣言しているんです
それで当然しつけがあるんです
それで自分の格がどんどんどんどんどんどん上がっていくんですね
株じゃなくてね 格が 上がっていって
悟りに達したら お釈迦様は悟りに達しているって
その人も悟りに達する
その時でも戦友なんです
仲間なんです 別に一致団結して強くなろうぞって
そういう話じゃないんです
だから 和合やらね もう喧嘩しないこと
仲良くすることをとことん語っている仏教は
世間で言っているみんな一緒にいたら力強いよって
その話は通ってないんです
すごい微妙に違いますよ
出家に対してはもう完璧に和合を守りなさいと認めませんよ
微妙にでも色んなやら変な言い方とかね
わがままで自分のやり方でやると何のことなく無視するんです
その人は 出家の中では
破門したりは 反論する権利ないんだからね
しない 見事に無視するんです
すごく厳しい で 多数決は禁止
決まる場合も 何でもみんなで同じ意見で決めなくちゃいけない
同じ意見になるためには厳しいと
ブッダの意見に行かないと
だから自分の意見だったらどうせ多数決になるんです
私はこう思います 私 こう
じゃあ私の意見に賛成する人ってなるんです
それさえもないんです
だから見事な団結組織ですけど
でも 世間の一団結する世界とはずいぶん違う道なんです
だからそこでブッダの意見に団結するんです
個人の意見はもう跡形もなく潰すんです
個人の好みとか生き方からはもう通じませんね
だから個人のそのそれさえも潰すんだから
これそれにしても この磯野を切ることなんですよ
自我をなくすことなんです
そういうことで どんどんもう悟りを目指して頑張ると
だからこの我々人間はものすごい厳密に気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
なぜならば 我々はもういくら嫌だと思っても影響は受けるということが
躾を受けたということなんです
周りの影響を受けたということは
それからその影響に合わせて生きるということなんです
もう躾を受けているんです
これはもう避けられません
ずっといろいろ躾を受けちゃうんです
だから ずっと生きる上で気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
すごいいるでしょう この私は人の話は聞きません
偉そうなこと もう限ってその人々はもろに受けるんです
影響を これはもう人間は呼吸しなくちゃいけないぐらいのものなんですよ
私は空気が大嫌いやと
何言ってるんですかね
私は空気なんか大嫌いやとか言いながら呼吸してるんだからね
だから人は呼吸することと同じく
我々は毎日時間ぐらいほど影響を受けたりするんですよ
もう時間っておかしいと思う
夢見たら影響受けるでしょうね
夢でいろんな人が出たり
いろんなことあったりで
それからまたそれに悩んだりとか
また影響を受けたりとか
だからもう躾からは逃げられません
だから気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
どういう躾を受けるべきかという
その場合は 心強くと悪い影響が入るところは切らないと
自分の幸福っていうのは築くことはできないんです
はい では次に最終的な問題は
どうやって悪人と判断するのかというね
自分まだ未熟で あなたとは付き合います
あなたとは付き合えませんと
そんな判断できるでしょうね
どうやって小学生が私はあの学校に決めますとかね
あの学校はよくわかるわけないですよ
まだ入ってもないんだから
よくこの高校生になってくるとよく悩んだりするでしょ
自分で 次もどんな高校を選ぶかとか決めなくちゃあかんでしょうに
なんでその時すごく悩むのかというね
なんとなく自分でも決めなくちゃいけないことになっているんです
小学校の場合は 親が決めて入れてくれるんだから
全然心配しなかったんです
中学校もそのまま延長線でいくんだから決まっていて
その学校に入って 高校になってくると
やっぱり自分でも考えなくちゃいかんですよ
そのどんな子供でも その時はよく悩みますよ
この間 誰か若者がそのことですごく悩んでるんだ
私にどうすればいいかと
私は何のことはよく悩んでくださいと
それはもうなんとか裏口で助けることできるんですよ
ここはどうしようかとものすごく悩んで
まあよく悩んでくださいと
これは大変なことだと
それで今日それであなたの人生全部決めますからと
なおさらもっと厳しくしてあげる
そこで悩むのはもう一部自分でも判断しなくちゃいけないんだけど
経験ないんだからどうやって判断するんですかね
だからその経験はすごくいいんですよ
偉そうなことを判断するじゃなくてね
やっぱり判断できる資格はないということ
だから この我々は誰と付き合うべきかということはどうやって決めるのかと
誰が善人か 誰が悪人かというね
はい その時はやっぱり偉大なる善人たる偉大なる善友であるブッダに聞くしかないんです
他 誰に聞いても間違った道をしっかり教えてあげるんです
はい それで仏教はもう差別反対ですけど
差別があります しっかりと人を区別するんです
しっかりと区別しながら
差別は反対です どういうことかというと
この善と悪の問題なんです
人は行為で決めるんだよと
平等なんですけど 行為で差が付きますよと
単なる基本的に生命として平等だけであって
実際はないんだよと 実際は行為が生きることですね
だから結局は行為で差がつきますよと
だからそれはすごい科学的
ものすごい現実的な話なんです
国によって 民族によって
喋る言語によって差がつくんとは言わないんです
信仰によって差がつくとかないんです
例えば他の宗教では もう必ず神を信じる者と信じない者と区別つけちゃって
信じない人々は殺すんですね
平気で 人間失格やと そういうことは仏教でないんです
行為で差がつきますよと
だから神を信じても信じなくても
そんなの関係ないんだ
あんた人殺したでしょ
人殺しやと あんた強盗したで
あんた強盗やと で 社会ですごい偉い人やと
例えば徳川家の人やとまだいますからね
一応いるんです それ関係ないんですよ
悪いことしたら あんたはもう賄賂を取ったでしょうと
これ泥棒やと あんた嘘ついたでしょ
嘘つきやと そういう行為で人を選別するんです
そういうわけで どんな人間にもいつでも自由です
立派な人になるか卑しい人になるかということは
それはいつでもペンディングで
もう最終決断はないんです
例えば二十歳まで本当にいい子で
良いことよく勉強して
悪いこと何もしないでいたならば
二十歳までの評価はあんたはすごい立派な人間であると
しかし いつでも日にち
この日まであんたは立派な人間でいたことは証明できるということはできます
しかし  二十一から何するかって
これは別な話で 二十歳まで何も悪いことしてないで
本当にみんなに褒められる生活をしても
二十一歳になったところで人殺したら
あんたは人殺しであると
今までのキャラクターは全部それで終わってしまうんです
だからいつでもオープンで
今オープンという言葉にみんなわかるオープン
品物を大体今は値段書かないのでオープン価格と書いているです
特に電気製品の場合はね
だからオープン価格って意味わかるでしょ？店によって値段が違うっていうことなんです
そんな感じで 人の価値はいつでもオープン価格なんです
行為によって決めてしまいます
そういうわけで 我々は毎日気をつけて行為しなくちゃいけない
いつでも良い行為をする羽目になるんです
良い行為はどこまでやればいいかということは成り立たないんです
どこまでかといったら
それから悪い行為したってもいいということじゃないでしょうに
だから どこまででも善行為を行わなくちゃいけないんです
差別反対仏教はもう激しく差別するんです
行為によって判断するんです
それも人を馬鹿にするためじゃなくて
自分が誰と付き合うのかと人を選ぶ場合は
自分のために この人は嘘を言う
この人は悪行為をする
いわゆる善悪で判断するんです
学歴じゃないんです 高校にも入ってない人であっても
生活は正しくて 悪いことは全くしない
すごい正直者で ものすごい真面目に頑張る人だったら専業ですよ
自分が東大卒業であっても
その人を付き合った方がいいんです
ものすごい楽しい人生になりますよ
性格で人を選ぶと 金で選んだりすると最悪なんです
見た目で選んだりするともう最悪なんです
学歴でどんな会社の社員だと
だから学歴で弁護士であろうが
国会議員で全然そんなの関係ないんです
医者であっても 弁護士であっても
科学者であっても それはもう評価リストに入りません
善行為をする人か悪行為をする人かということで決着つけます
だから我々は気をつける
悪人というのは悪行為をする
生命は殺すは嘘を言うは盗むことをするは
もういろんなからくりをするは詐欺をやるは資料ごまかしたりするは
水増すとなんとかやりますね
そういうことをするはどうかね
昨日かな テレビで見ていたんですけど
この 笑い番組なんですけど
この北海道で警察庁でなんか賄賂を取って
なんかもう裏金を作ってという事件が起きて
その人がね まあ裁かれちゃって大変なことになって
それで調べたら まあそちらみんな裏金を作っていると
だから本人が言ったのは
まあこの 若者を見てね
まあ笑い番組だからね
まあ自分がやってる悪いことはもう 100 まで
発表するならば許してもよろしいという太田さんの番組でね
という国会の模擬感じでね
で それ見事に却下されましたけどね
そこでみんな色々議論ね
国会スタイルで議論をやるというね
まあ笑い番組なんですけど
いろいろ本当に意見 立派な意見交わしたりするんです
だからこの若者たちはそれに反対ですね
一応この警察の元人が言ったのは
あんた方の気持ちは分かりますよと
私もそういうすごい正直で素直で生きていきたいと思っていたんだよと
しかし この悪いことをする人々は
自分たちが悪いことをしているという実感さえもないんだと
だから守屋さんなんか悪くないんだと
何で悪いと決めるんでしょうかと
ただバレただけやと だから彼をむくっとこと批判するのは良くないんだと
そういう警察官って来て
あの人言ったのは この自分が警察に入ったところでびっくりしたんだと
いろいろごまかしをして裏金を作ったりして
それで自分がまだ入ったばっかりだから
もう何も言えないんだと
これやりなさいと言ったら
みんなそこはもう当たり前のことをやっているんだと
それでちゃんとそこでみすまししたり
資料ごまかしたりして
裏金をたくさん作って政治家にあげたりすると
昇格ってのは簡単だよと
だから自分もちゃんとみんなと一緒に
組織はそうやってできていて
自分が後から入ったんであって
どんどんやっていっただけやと
最終的にはもう誰か犯人にしなくちゃいけないんだから
自分が犯人になっただけやと
その時はトップになっていたんだから
トップになってると他の部下に命令しなくちゃいかんし
だからまあそういうことやと
それでも 我々はやっぱり
他人の影響を受けますからね
何のことなく 周りのね
だからこのはっきりとこの善行為をする人が良い人で
悪い行為をする人が悪人だと判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで気をつけて生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから善悪ははっきりリストありますからね
盗むことやらね 人殺すことやら
詐欺やることやら もうそういう賄賂取ったりとかね
裏金でなんとかやって
だからそういう人を付き合っちゃうと
なんか自分もやらなくちゃいけないことになってしまうんですね
だから学歴とかね はあまり気を全然気にしない方がいいんです
どんな会社の社長かとか
もうそんなに気にしない方がいいんです
どんな大学卒業してる方
国会議員だから偉い人だから付き合いますよとかね
そういう基準は仏教的にはあまり気にしない方がいいんです
国会議員であってもいろいろやっているならば
付き合っちゃうと先に自分が捕まりますよ
そういうことでまあ 生活は気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
それからこの影響力 こちらの次のことは Purisa adamma というね
adamma というのはすっごい卑しいという意味なんです worst
と英語で言えばね ワースト
adamma というのはワーストという意味で使う言葉なんですね
こちらの Purisadame と書いてますね
これは Purisa adamma という 2つの単語をつなげて Purisadamma と読むんですね
最悪という意味なんです
もう一番卑しいという
これ一番卑しいというのは影響力ある人なんです
例えば自分で悪いことしたっても
相手あまり影響力ないと相手を引っ張ることできるんでしょうに
ただ 悪人の中でも影響力強い人はいるんです
カリスマ的な人 カリスマ的な人だったら
もう仲間みんな言うことやっちゃうんです
それはもう最低に卑しい人になっちゃうんです
だからただ嘘をつく人
詐欺はただの嘘つきで詐欺師なんです
その上カリスマ的だったら
もう話にもならないんです
周りの人々は結構自分の世界に引いちゃうんです
そういうわけで  2つに言葉分けてますよ
悪人とパパダマという人と付き合うなよと
ちゃんとお釈迦様が言葉単語 2つ使ってるんです
悪人と言えば悪行為するだけで影響力あったりなかったり
もう様々 私は嫌 ああそうか
あんた嫌ですか じゃあいいよということにもなる場合あるんですよ
じゃあ私一人でやりますよと
影響力ある人はそうじゃないんです
私はこういうことをやりたいと思っています
やるやるやります やりますよと言っちゃいますよ
次の人は この人のすごいカリスマ的だから一緒にやりたいんです
だから皆様みんな仲間のことで
よく調べてみても  2ついますよ
悪いことするだけじゃなくて
カリスマ的な人間でもあると
だからそこはだからいい人だと順番逆なんで
仏教で悪いことする人よりもひどいんだ
カリスマ的な であるならば
これが adamma なんで
Purisa adamma
最低の人間と悪人と最低の人間と 2つ分けてるんです
良い場合も善人と最高な人間と 2つ分けてます
良い良いことする人間の中で自分がすごい良いことをするんですけど
人にまで勧める能力はない
カリスマ的なパワーがないんです
それは良い人 自分も良いことするだけじゃなくて
周りにも影響を与えて周りにも良いことをさせる人が Purisa Uttama 素晴らしい優れた人ということになるんです
だからカリスマ的のカリスマ的であることはどちらにつくかと
どちらにつけても重みが重いので重みがあるんです
悪の方についちゃうと
ものすごい悪のどん底に落ちてしまうし
善の方になってくるとすごい高くなってしまうんですね
はい  そんなことで そういうわけでね
仏教ではね 悪い人と付き合うなよという
そんなのは当たり前 もうお母さんにも教えてくれたものだからということではないんです
悪いことというのは これ日本語で読んでも
なんだまあ当たり前のことですね
ブッダが言ってることはという風になりますけどね
ブッダはそこ違う人間なんですよ
当たり前のことでもないんです
おっしゃってることは
で だからそこは仏教はいろんなことを学んでいかないと
こういうふうには分析はできないんです
よくよく学んでないと
で だから今日の私の解説も
ただこの四行だけ見て解するんじゃなくて
あらゆるところでお釈迦様がおっしゃったところを考えながら考えながらもう解説していくんです
だから 友人が確実に必要であるというふうに言ってますよ
悟りに達する人にとっては
戦友がなく成り立ちませんよと
そこまで言ってますからね
ということは 生命は本来もう躾を受けるようにできているんです
だから仏道も躾という一言葉で言ってます
この三学 師匠がありますね
戒定慧と 仏道は戒定慧であると
三つも学なんです それで修行する人は有学で悟った人は無学にしているんだから
悉皆という言葉から抜けられません
だから無学というのは学問がない人やって意味じゃないんです
躾が終わったっていう意味なんです
悟ったっていうことなんです
だから学 学ぶという一言葉で全部言ってます
だからとても大事な言葉なんですよ
仏教においては学ぶということ
仏教はあえて教えるんじゃなくて
これが自然法則なんです
仏教の強いところはそこなんです
言ってることは あえてわざわざこれは神の言葉だからっていうふうに
この異物持ってくるんじゃないんです
神の言葉 聖書の言葉というのはいつでも異物ですからね
人間に神が汝はこういうふうにしないと語っていることだからね
異物なんですね そうなってくると
仏教はそうじゃなくて
状況を分析して説明するんだから科学なんですね
科学者は何か持ってくることしないでしょう
あるものを分析して状況を説明する
そういうことで 学ということはあることなんです
生命の 生命でいる限りは
もういつでも学ぶということはもう抜けられません
それで学ぶということは整理整頓して
物理法則を発見した科学者たちがあらゆるものを作ったり作ったりして
ロボットまで作ったりするでしょうに
で 例えばこの細菌とかね
危ない危ない危ないと思っているんですけど
この遺伝子改良して治療する場合は細菌使ってますよ
いろいろバクテリアを捕まかってバクテリアの遺伝子を一部抜けちゃって
それにその人間に必要な
遺伝子を埋め替えて そこでバクテリアを創り出して体に注射するだけの話で
この最終 これからの治療法っていうのはね
オーダーメイドになるという話でしょ
それで体のDNAを改良して病気を治しちゃうという
それに役に立つのはやっぱり結局はあの悪いバクテリアなんです
だからそれは科学の思考なんですよ
まあ仏教も昔から同じことよ
だから学ぶということはどんな生命にもあることだったら
それはしっかりしましょうよと
ちゃんと分けて学ぶべきものと学ぶべきでないものを区別して
どこまで学ぶのかという
じゃあ学ぶことは完了するまでやりましょうと
いうことで 何を学べば完了するのか
生命のことを学べば完了するんだよと
生きることを学べば完了するんだよと
どう生きればいいかと学んだっても完了しません
普通人間の問題は 私はどう生きればいいか
どう生きたって意味がないんです
輪廻転生するんだから
私は何をすればいいか
のこのこで何でもいいよ
勝手にやってください
それじゃなくて 生きるとは何かという学んだら
もう学びは完了するんです
それで無学ということになります
はい それで終了したいと思います
今日は一偈だけで あまりもう二偈まで行こうかなと思ったんですけども
今みんなキリスト教になってますからね
もうまあ直したら悪いんだからね
[ページをめくる音]